[Música]
sin repetir sin soplar y sin google
les voy a pedir que levanten la mano
aquellas personas que no puedan decir
cuántos son los integrantes de la
primera junta del 25 de mayo de 1810
déjenme que les agradezca que no hayan
levantado la mano porque me hubieran
arruinado la charla
ahora los voy a invitar a hacer un
experimento social conmigo
para eso necesito que cierren los ojos
cierren los ojos por favor vamos a
retrotraernos a nuestros 12 años estamos
aproximadamente en sexto séptimo grado
cuál es el nombre de su mejor amigo o de
su mejor amiga cuál es el nombre de ese
docente favorito que todos teníamos
y el nombre del chico o la chica que nos
gustaba ya pueden abrir los ojos
ahora sí les voy a pedir que levanten la
mano a aquellas personas que lo pueden
recordar
gracias quiero confesarles que yo
tampoco recuerdo cuántos son los
integrantes de la primera junta
pero si recuerdo aquel acto escolar
donde tuve que interpretar a una
vendedora de empanadas recuerdo a mi
abuela cosiendo me la pollera recuerdo a
mi mamá pintando me la cara con corcho
quemado
también recuerdo la copla que tenía que
recitar
empanaditas calientes para las criollas
valientes bueno no viene el caso
pero porque podemos recordar ese tipo de
datos y no podemos recordar datos
fácticos como la primera pregunta que
les hice porque esos hechos tienen que
ver con nuestra vida con nuestra
historia porque dejaron una huella en
nosotros por eso son significativos y
por eso los recordamos
de la misma manera le sucede a quien fue
víctima de bullying
cuando tenía 12 años
comencé a hablar con otras personas a
través de la webcam
y así conocí muchos chicos y muchas
chicas
hice varios amigos o al menos eso creía
un día conocí a un chico que fue
especial que me decía muchas cosas
lindas me decía que yo era muy
inteligente que le gustaba
ese chico un día me pidió una foto
una foto de mis lolas
y yo no estaba dispuesta a enviarle esa
foto
no si esas cosas
pero fue tan insistente
y yo no quería perder su relación la
relación que teníamos era tan profunda
yo no veía a la hora de llegar a mi casa
para conectarme y hablar con él
así que pensé bueno es simplemente una
foto que puede pasar
pero después él siguió exigiendo me más
fotos
y yo no estuve dispuesta así que salí de
ese blog y nunca más volví a entrar
un año más tarde
cree en mi primera página de facebook
y me llegó un mensaje de esta persona
que me seguía pidiendo más fotos y me
amenazaba con compartir la que ya tenía
con todos mis contactos
al principio no creí que esto pudiera
pasar
pero en unas vacaciones de navidad
comenzaron a llegar mensajes de mis
amigas de mis amigos
que me decían que había una página de
facebook cuya foto de perfil era mi foto
yo no lo podía creer sentía una
vergüenza muy grande pensaba cómo se lo
iba a decir a mis padres
quise desaparecer
cerré mis redes sociales
tenía la esperanza de que si no salía en
mi casa en todo el verano la gente se
iba a olvidar de mi foto
pero esto no fue así
el primer día de clases del que sería mi
último año
no solamente no se habían olvidado sino
que podía ver cuando estaba en el
colegio como me observaban
o sea nadie quería ser mi amiga mi amigo
comencé a transitar un oscuro túnel de
soledad y angustia
mi interés en el colegio comenzó a
decrecer mis notas bajaron ya no podía
concentrarme a la escuela
mis padres no sabían cómo ayudarme
comencé a hacer terapia porque
simultáneamente comencé a tener ataques
de pánico
recurrir a las drogas
lo único que me causaba sensación de
tranquilidad era la idea de desaparecer
y esa idea comenzó a rondar cada vez con
mayor frecuencia en mi cabeza
la sola idea de dejar de existir era lo
único que me alentaba
esta historia es una historia real
es la historia de amanda tu mandato es
una adolescente canadiense
que a los 15 años decidió quitarse la
vida
esto sucedió en canadá en el año 2012
antes de quitarse la vida amanda
confecciona un vídeo de youtube
a donde hace un último pedido de ayuda
mientras estaba estudiando mi carrera y
casi por casualidad con este vídeo que
me impactó muchísimo
por qué
el suicidio fue una decisión terminante
para un problema que podría haber sido
circunstancial
y lo primero que pensé es esto podría
haberse evitado
el físico es la segunda causa de muerte
en la adolescencia la primera son los
accidentes de tránsito la segunda es el
suicidio
en nuestro país según datos oficiales de
la organización mundial de la salud esta
tasa se ha triplicado desde la década
del 90 hasta la actualidad
no todos los casos terminan de la misma
manera por supuesto y el bullying
tampoco es la única causa de suicidio
pero si actúa como un precipitado por la
sensación de soledad y de aislamiento en
la que se encuentra esa víctima
tener amigos es un factor de protección
pero no sólo eso también causa un daño
en nuestra autoestima que es la
percepción que tenemos de nosotros
mismos y esto tiene consecuencias
directas en nuestra vida como adultos
la confianza en nosotros mismos es la
que nos permite ponernos metas superar
obstáculos por eso considero que la
escuela no debe centrarse solamente en
la adquisición de conocimientos
académicos es fundamental que también
pongamos el foco en la enseñanza de
competencias emocionales y esas
habilidades sociales las vamos a
utilizar no solamente como adultos toda
la vida como niños como adultos como
pareja de alguien como hija de alguien
les voy a pedir una última consigna
mirarse a los ojos
en silencio mirarse a los ojos
es muy difícil es muy incómodo
y estamos acostumbrados a mirar a la
pantalla del celular
pero no podemos sostener por más de un
instante la mirada con otra persona
las relaciones sociales cada vez están
más deshumanizadas
hemos perdido la habilidad de ponernos
en el lugar de otra persona
cuántas veces alguien nos hace un halago
y no sabemos cómo recibirlo cuántas
veces nos encontramos teniendo que pedir
un favor y no sabiendo cómo hacer
esa discapacidad se llama
dificultad para tener habilidades
sociales este tipo de habilidades a
veces las tenemos naturalmente otras
veces las podemos ejercitar y las
podemos adquirir
la empatía como les decía anteriormente
es una de esas habilidades es la
capacidad de ponernos en el lugar del
otro comprenderlo y regular nuestra
respuesta emocional
y esa capacidad de empatía combinada con
el respeto hacia el otro como alguien
diferente a mí estoy convencida es la
solución al flagelo del bullying muchas
gracias